desde finales de los 50 bajo el
liderazgo del general de gaulle francia
se convirtió en el tercer país en
establecer una agencia espacial la cn s
para lanzar su programa de cohetes y
enviar un animal al espacio luego llegó
el turno de los humanos un total de 10
astronautas han visto la tierra desde el
espacio o nave no importa cuánto veas
fotos y películas de la tierra tomadas
desde el espacio cuando con tus propios
ojos te mueves hacia la portilla por
primera vez y la miras es guau
[Música]
si con el virus es como una joya es más
hermoso que el mejor cuadro pintado por
el mejor pintor de la historia después
de que son sólo el caso el pionero se
llamó jean luc gestión en 1982 fue el
primer europeo occidental en abandonar
la tierra un hecho de suma importancia
después jean-pierre en llegue fue el
primero en realizar una misión de larga
duración seis meses a bordo de la
estación mir y su esposa claudia que fue
la primera y única francesa en el
espacio pero la misión más notable para
un astronauta francés se dio en 1999 a
quinientos sesenta y nueve kilómetros de
la tierra el telescopio hubble se
descompuso la nasa formó en sólo seis
meses una de las misiones con más
experiencia de la historia para salvar
el telescopio ese fue el tercer viaje de
jean françois clervoy el especialista en
brazos articulados mide 15 metros de
largo tiene hombro codo muñeca tuve dos
rondas de pilotaje para realizar
rotaciones y traslación es al mismo
tiempo en seis direcciones diferentes
captura el telescopio lo puse en la
bodega luego los días siguientes movía a
los compañeros atados al final del brazo
el día de navidad lancé el telescopio al
espacio y después de algunas órbitas nos
llamaron discovery
houston el telescopio está 100%
operativo así que ese fue nuestro mejor
regalo de navidad el décimo y último
astronauta franceses thomas pesquet
ahora en su segunda estancia a bordo de
la estación espacial
será el primero en comandar la